The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Okay.
So this is our second
session with Phil
[? Scarf, ?] please welcome him.
So we're going to have
our presentations based
on the design assignment
that Phil came up with.
So who would like
to go for first?
There you go.
Thank you.
PHIL SCARF: Can you
tell us your design?
STUDENT 1: So we chose a raga.
We decided on the notes
C, Db, F, G and Bb.
And we went with a
more traditional,
where you start out slow and
you slowly expand the range.
And then you add in
more players and then
you play a melody line together
and then alternate whoever
is improvising.
And then we did a little
bit of extrapolation
halfway through by
changing one of the notes
in the raga actually.
And just for a little different
style and then we go back.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL SCARF: That
was very impressive.
So let me just ask
the performers.
Did that performance go the
way you envisioned it going?
Since we're
improvising, you never
know what's going to happen
when you improvise, right?
So I'm just curious
if that's the way
you had planned for it to go,
or you thought that anything
might have been different.
STUDENT 1: So when
I was describing it
I said there was
a section where we
change one of the
notes in the raga.
That didn't happen.
At the end, we had the option
of going into that or stopping.
PHIL SCARF: Anything else?
STUDENT 2: So we sort of knew
vaguely what different sections
were going to be
like, and sort of what
we would try and do with them.
But that was completely
different -- like, we tried,
we run through it a couple
of times before, today.
That was kind of different
to what we'd done before.
PHIL SCARF: That's
improvisation.
It should be different.
That's actually the point.
If you start doing the same
thing over and over again,
it's no longer
improvisation, right?
So that's great.
Good.
So any comments
from anybody else?
Any thoughts?
STUDENT 3: There were
a couple of times
when you played in unison,
and I didn't really
see any cues into
those sections.
I was just wondering if you were
all improvising, how did you
move from improvisational
section to unison section?
STUDENT 4: We have this
one particular melody,
so when one person started, we
could recognize that melody.
Or one person began it,
we would go into it.
And there was a couple
times we repeated it,
so one person would
get to the end of it
and then we'd go
straight into it again.
PHIL SCARF: Any other comments?
PROFESSOR: I'll
just say, I thought
it worked very well as a
composed improvisation.
I thought the framework
was well thought out.
And the realization
through improvisation
made a lot of sense.
Very good.
PHIL SCARF: I think you
really captured the frameworks
very well.
Why don't you want
to tell us about it?
Because everybody needs to know.
STUDENT 4: So basically we
came up with our own scale
to base the improvisation on.
And we decided to look into
the range and note density
frameworks at first.
So we're each starting
in different parts
of our register, which is
maybe different than what
would be done
traditionally, perhaps.
But then we'll move
out and expand,
which is pretty similar to some
of the stuff that happens with
[INAUDIBLE].
And then we'll also be moving
from pretty simple melodies
and pretty simple [INAUDIBLE]
to more complicated things
that come up and we'll
try to then [INAUDIBLE].
It won't start with
a [INAUDIBLE] rhythm,
but then we'll try to get into
a rhythmic groove later on.
STUDENT 6: One more thing, I'm
going to start with a drone,
to imitate the
tambura, and we're
going to add ornamentation
to the melodies,
to imitate [INAUDIBLE].
PHIL SCARF: OK, sounds good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL SCARF: Nice.
So any thoughts
about that piece?
So did the performance
went the way you expected?
Did you do anything different
that you were thinking about?
STUDENT 6: I'd say in general,
the note density and range
[INAUDIBLE].
We were hoping to get a motif
in there, but I don't think --
STUDENT 5: We were going to
just let it develop organically.
But we just kind of
played off each other.
STUDENT 6: And the rhythm wasn't
3-3-2 like we were predicting,
it did settle.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah, it did
become rhythmic, about halfway
through.
Yeah, good.
Anything else?
[INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT 5: Yeah, a
little bit, yeah.
PROFESSOR: And then
you jump right on.
STUDENT 6: Well yeah, I
used the bass to really --
PROFESSOR: But that was
very good listening,
because it didn't take
more than a second or two
to really coalesce.
And how about the ending?
Had that been thought about?
STUDENT 5: We
planned to just bring
the range back in,
basically, to where
we had been in the beginning.
That fade-out,
literally fade out.
PHIL SCARF: That
worked out great.
Anybody else have any comments?
Any thoughts, observations?
Yeah.
STUDENT 7: Well
in the beginning,
I thought the piano
player was going
to drone on for the entire song,
and just sort of be a drone.
And I was waiting
for him to come in,
and finally I felt
relieved when he
came in and built on the violin.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah
STUDENT 6: Yeah, we didn't have
any unison melodies planned,
so I didn't want it to be
really dense too early.
PHIL SCARF: I mean, I thought
that was nice, you know?
Because we had one solo voice
with a kind of accompaniment,
and then it became
more of a duet.
So there was an element
of progression there.
STUDENT 6: Another thing
we didn't anticipate,
Austin focused on the
mid-upper part of the scale,
and I was just doing the
first three or four notes.
PHIL SCARF: Anything else?
Cool.
OK.
Next group.
STUDENT 8: So I actually didn't
come up with my own scale.
I just decided to use
the D Dorian mode.
It's a little bit more humble
for me to play around with.
My vision is around the piano to
form a sort of drone, in low D.
And use that, and also drone,
and then as a little bit goes
on, build up into a [INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE] necessary.
It starts at
[INAUDIBLE] but then
I do have a melodic motif that
I was going to center it around.
PHIL SCARF: Can I just
ask, is the melodic thing
a raga or scale idea?
STUDENT 8: I just came up
with something on the guitar.
PHIL SCARF: So are there
any specific frameworks
from the set of 12
that we're using here?
STUDENT 8: I was looking
at -- I can't remember --
there were two [INAUDIBLE]
I was looking at.
Looking at a little
bit no density.
Kind of applying it towards the
[INAUDIBLE] notes, or the lower
end.
So the drone has a
little bit of freedom,
in terms of picking up,
as he wants to [INAUDIBLE]
tremolo, rhythmic
framework, I guess.
PHIL SCARF: So is
the note density
going to change
throughout the piece?
Or not?
Yes.
Do you have a view of
how that would change?
Or is that going
to be improvised?
STUDENT 8: I envisioned it as
starting out slow, building up,
more dense, little faster,
slowing down towards the end.
And the other one I was looking
at was using the framework,
the little melody, I guess,
and working that around --
I can't remember
what it was called --
PHIL SCARF: Oh, the
[INAUDIBLE] maybe?
That's what you mean?
Melodic motif.
Yeah.
Good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
That was good.
I like that amp.
That's pretty convenient.
So any comments
from the performers?
I'm particularly interested
in what the collaborators may
think about this,
since they didn't have
much notice before
playing the piece.
STUDENT 9: I didn't
have any idea what
it would be like going into it.
But having the
framework really set
an expectation of
gradually increasing
note density and the range.
And having the motif
definitely helps.
PHIL SCARF: That motif was cool.
And the way that it
was used was good.
STUDENT 10: I think it
was just enough to provide
a cool little phrase to work on.
STUDENT 8: That was one
of the visions I had.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
That was great.
The first group that's used
the [? chellan ?] framework,
so that's good.
Any other comments?
What about the designer?
Do you have any comments
about how this went?
STUDENT 8: I just didn't know
what to expect going into it.
Because again, I just sort of
did this myself, yesterday.
And I didn't know
what the performers
would think going into this.
And from the outset, I
knew, I guess the piano
sort of provided the
rhythmic background, I guess.
And set the overall tone.
And then I came in
with some free time
before I settled into the motif.
And then everybody settled
around that, as well.
PHIL SCARF: Anybody
else have any thoughts?
Observations, comments?
STUDENT 7: I really
liked that motif.
It really brought
it all together.
And I think it gave
the collaborators
a really solid
base to start from.
And build off of.
Seems like a cool way
improvise and make a framework.
Just start with a tiny
motif and then see
where you can take
it from there.
PHIL SCARF: Exactly.
And then, the listener also
gravitates towards that,
as well.
Every time it comes back,
it's familiar material.
In fact, I think that
kind of illustrates one
of the attractive elements
of Indian classical music
is use of [? chellan ?].
Even if it's something
you haven't heard before,
by the time you
finish hearing it,
you've heard the [? chellan, ?]
some of the key phrases, you've
heard them so many times,
it become familiar.
So like this motif, by
the time we finished,
it sounds like a familiar piece.
Even though none of us
had heard it before,
except perhaps, the composer.
So it's nice.
Any other thoughts?
So what's your framework?
Can you tell us
about your framework?
STUDENT 11: OK, so basically,
we based off a [INAUDIBLE]
in terms of -- we have a
motif that we start out with.
And then we're going
late on build on it
by adding some chords.
And then while one
person plays the melody,
the other person will
improvise on it, instead.
STUDENT 12: We had
wanted a beat to feed us.
He'll learn it.
STUDENT 11: OK.
You'll get the melody
after we play it.
So basically, us
two will play it,
and then you can come in
after four times or something.
And then we'll take
turns improving
while one person drones on a D.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL SCARF: So any thoughts?
How did you think it went?
STUDENT 11: I think
it went pretty well.
I think originally we were
supposed to play the melody
and then harmonize
a little bit to it.
And then kind of stretch
up from that melody.
But in the end, we just
started improvising instead
so I guess that worked out.
PHIL SCARF: But there
was harmony introduced
as the improvisation
evolved, too.
It's coo.
Any other comments or thoughts?
How about the flutist?
STUDENT 1: I was playing
in F natural for too long.
I was like there's probably
not an F# in this scale
if there's a Bb,
[INAUDIBLE] really confused.
[INAUDIBLE]
PHIL SCARF: Anybody
else, have any comments?
STUDENT 2: I thought
it was pretty cool how
the rhythmic moment
of the melody
became stronger
almost, throughout.
It was like a little more
free in the beginning,
maybe, when you
decided to push time.
[INAUDIBLE] almost
like a very driving.
PHIL SCARF: That's true.
Good observation.
It was very effective, too.
PROFESSOR: So that's the
second one that did that.
Where it evolved into
the rhythmic spectrum.
It's an interesting
way to do it.
STUDENT 13: So this
is D Mixolydian
rather than picking a new scale.
And [INAUDIBLE] Jamie
is going to set up
a low drone at the beginning.
And once Jamie has
this low drone,
the flute and trumpet come
in on vibrato type lines.
And then the flute
and trumpet explore
the different [INAUDIBLE].
So I tried it in a low
range, [INAUDIBLE] Flute
is going to start
with low note density
and gradually increase density.
Also Jamie is going to gradually
adopt a rhythmic progression
and eventually start playing
[? jala. ?] And I think you
said the [? jala ?] will be
in different rhythmic groups,
so that we also have a
little bit of [? livhari ?],
or rhythm play.
And that will go on
for a minute or two.
We don't really have
specifics of what's
going to happen in there,
it's just to improvise.
And at the end, I drop
out, flute drops out,
and then Jamie just sort
of continues with the drone
and fades out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL SCARF: Nice.
So do we have any thoughts
from the performers?
STUDENT 7: I thought
it went pretty well.
We just sort of set up
the framework last night
and just ran through it once.
We were like, alright, we'll
do something like that.
So it turned out similar manner.
Had sort of the same feel.
I think it went well.
STUDENT 13: I don't think it
sounded quite as Hindustani
as a raja, but was totally
using the framework.
Like it had the
same idea, and it
was easy to communicate
with someone
who just heard the
framework today, what to do.
PROFESSOR: I like the
rhythmic of the banjo.
You really sounded almost
like a mix between a tabla
and something, I'm
not quite what else.
STUDENT 7: Yeah, I almost
wanted to play it on my lap.
PHIL SCARF: Maybe more
like a [? surod, ?]
actually it's a little
like it's [? surod, ?]
which is played with a pick
and it's got more of an attack.
Cool.
How about the flutist?
Because this is
the first time you
had been introduced
to the piece.
Any comments?
STUDENT 1: I liked it,
it was easy to follow.
[INAUDIBLE] set up the
right image [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You're a
utility [INAUDIBLE],
we bring you in
whenever we need it.
Thank you for that.
PHIL SCARF: I was
going to say, I thought
it was cool because the way
you used the frameworks,
you had assigned different
frameworks to different people,
which was interesting.
First time, I think,
we did that today.
So that was cool.
Good idea.
STUDENT 7: I really
liked playing it
because it sort of fit
my instrument very well.
I could do like the
slower bluegrass picking,
and just leave that D open
the entire time pretty much,
and that leaves a nice drone.
That makes it easy to play
around on the top three strings
and it was a lot of fun.
STUDENT 13: Actually, the
reason we split up frameworks
is the first time we
decided what to do, Sarah
and I were both just like,
yeah, we can both do range,
we can both do note density.
And then we ended up running
through the piece once,
and I focused more on
range, and she focused more
on the note density.
So we said, well, why not
just make that the framework
instead?
PHIL SCARF: Yeah,
that's a great idea.
That is a very cool idea.
Excellent.
STUDENT 10: At the risk
of overworking the flutes,
can I ask one of you
guys to -- alright, cool.
So like most of
the other groups,
the frameworks we ended up
using are range and note density
again.
So I was going to start toward
the lower end of the range
and then gradually work up.
And then vice
versa for the oboe.
So I guess rhythmic
progression is just
like a natural part
of that, as well.
So we are thinking of playing
in concert G natural minor.
Yeah, so we're going to
start off just alternating,
with one person doing a
drone on the concert G.
And then the other person just
kind of soloing off of that.
And then just
interchanging a few times.
Maybe two or three
times or whatever.
And then, just gradually
working into playing together.
PHIL SCARF: That's cool.
And did you have a specific idea
about the rhythmic progression
and how that would work?
STUDENT 10: Just in the vague
sense of gradually speeding up.
Starting off with slower,
sustained whole notes
and working to faster rhythms.
We kind of wanted to work
some [? chellan ?] in there,
as well.
We don't have any kind of set
phrase we wanted to repeat.
I guess it's something
we kind of wanted
to figure out as we go.
If we find something
worth holding on to,
then we'll do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
Nice.
PROFESSOR: So you're just
coming into this cold, right?
So I noticed, you
were watching him.
Had you determined that
you would watch each other
and do those phrases toward
the end in synchrony?
STUDENT 2: That was
just based off his --
he said that he wanted to do
something with [? chellan, ?]
so I was trying to pick up
some very distinctive phrases
and see whether I can put
them into different ranges.
And so I picked out a
couple, and just tried
to repeat them and then
put them in different notes
with the same rhythm.
But by and large, most
of it was just like, oh,
that sounds nice.
PROFESSOR: Well I personally
thought it was very good,
the way it worked out, and
very interesting the way
it all synchronized.
I mean, it was like
you planned it.
Which obviously, you didn't.
STUDENT 10: Yeah, one problem
we ran into when Ben and I were
rehearsing was just, when we
got toward the end each time,
and we tried to make
the rhythm go faster,
it kind of became more
difficult to play in synchrony.
Because there's just so
much loudness going on.
PHIL SCARF: Anybody
else have comments?
STUDENT 7: You could
really tell you
could find that
[? challen ?] motif,
you repeated and played off of.
I think it worked out nicely.
PHIL SCARF: Anybody else?
PROFESSOR: I was just thinking,
it would be interesting.
We can do this through
the magic of taping,
to play all these
exactly in sequence.
And then hear them
as a unified suite.
Which we could do through
the mystery of taping.
[INAUDIBLE] It was
very interesting
how we started with a slower
idea doing some things.
Then we got more rhythmicized
as we got to the middle.
Then we had this as the ending.
Well, your thing just before
that and then this thing
at the end, which
is very different.
PHIL SCARF: Cool.
Thank you.
So what I thought is,
maybe, as a group,
we can try some of
the frameworks that
didn't get selected
for today's assignment.
So I was thinking,
why don't we do --
I forget what I called
it, the constrained range.
Confined range, OK.
So there's one called
[? tans ?] confined range.
And then we have the expanding
and contracting [? tans. ?]
So maybe we can try those.
And actually, why don't we as
a group figure out a a design?
Why should I say
what the design is?
Let's use those frameworks.
And who wants to
volunteer, who wants
to give us an idea
of how we can start?
Or how to use the frameworks?
I see an elbow going up.
You got to be careful.
It's like you're at
an auction, and if you
do something like that, you
just bought it, you know?
OK, well I know you
guys been thinking
about these for a while.
Yes, go ahead.
STUDENT 7: Normally with range,
we start low and then go high,
why don't we start high
and slowly incorporate
the low notes?
PHIL SCARF: That's fine.
That's cool.
And so that takes care of range.
But who can think of what to do
with this confined range idea?
And then expanding
and contracting.
What could we do with
those two things?
When you say start
high and move low,
did you mean we have the
confined range times?
OK.
So the confined range
times, we'll start high.
And then what are
we going to do?
STUDENT 7: Expand
them slowly out?
PHIL SCARF: So expanding.
OK.
Right.
So expanding more down, because
we're going to start high.
So expanding them down.
And when we do the
expanding and contracting,
these are more like linear.
So you're kind of
going up and down,
progressively up and down.
So you would make the point,
if you're expanding downwards,
you'll say you'll start here,
and go down and back up.
And then go down,
farther and back up,
and then farther and back up.
Every time, you go progressively
farther and farther.
And then, is that it?
Or anybody else have
anything else to add?
STUDENT 13: Maybe
when we contract,
we can contract the top note,
so that the top end of the range
is getting lower.
And then we can track
down to the bottom tonic.
PHIL SCARF: That
is a killer idea.
I love that.
OK.
So that's good.
And then, anything else?
I think that's enough.
So I think we can
play with that.
So let's just review
this one more time,
make sure I got this right, OK?
I'm going to try to summarize
what I think we're doing.
So we're starting with
a constrained range
or confined range
[? tans, ?] which
are fast lines, as opposed
to these slow lines which
everybody's been starting with.
So we're starting
something fast.
But you've got to
pick just a few notes.
Like three or four notes, and
just stick with those notes
and just keep going fast
passages using those notes.
And then after a
while, we're going
to start doing expanding
and contracting,
expanding [? tans. ?]
Expanding downwards,
progressively farther downwards.
And then start doing it
but reducing the upper part
of the range, and then wind
up with some probably confined
range, constrained range
[? tan ?] at the bottom.
Yeah.
OK.
Great.
So any questions
or anything about?
Does that reflect what
you guys want to do?
STUDENT 13: Do you want
to pick a mode or the key?
PHIL SCARF: That's
a great question.
I am tempted to say no.
Because everybody's doing that.
So I think we should
do something different.
My two cents is no.
No.
That's just my two cents.
Because everybody seems
to be still worrying
about the modes and the scales.
STUDENT 13: But there's
like a dozen of us.
Won't it --
PHIL SCARF: OK.
You guys, feel free
to override me.
My two cents is I wouldn't
get too worried about it.
But if you want to pick
a starting note maybe.
That might be good.
STUDENT 4: We can try both.
We can try it twice.
We could just try both.
We could just try
it as you say first,
and then see what
it sounds like.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
Because, hey, we can
always do it again.
So let's try it without
overly defining this too much.
And see how it goes.
And then we can talk
about it, and see
if it's something
we want to change.
How about that?
All right.
So I'm going to let
you guys start --
maybe I won't even play.
I'll let you guys play,
why do I need to play?
Is everybody ready?
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL SCARF: Cool.
OK.
That was nice.
So any thoughts about this?
STUDENT 13: One thing I noticed,
is by the time we ended,
I think, most people already
done the contracting,
and I hadn't.
And it was just very difficult
to listen to other people,
to figure about what kind
of range they were in.
Since everyone was in a
different part of their range.
I couldn't just listen to
the sax and be like, oh yeah,
he's in the low
part of his range.
Because listening to the
flute or the banjo would like
get me sort of confused about
what range everyone was in.
PHIL SCARF: Well there's
so many people playing.
It's pretty thick with
everybody playing.
You know, the thing, in Indian
classical music, of course,
normally there would
be one lead performer,
one lead melodic performer.
There might be two if it's
like a duel under your duet
kind of program.
There would typically be
an accompanist or even two,
but they would be playing a much
more secondary role, usually.
So we wouldn't have this
kind of size ensemble.
Wouldn't happen.
So these frameworks,
really, we can certainly
apply them to a large ensemble.
Traditionally, it
wouldn't be like this.
Any other comments or thoughts?
STUDENT 12: I felt like
we sort of ended up
finding a modal
center, but we had
some type of tonal
center of some sort.
I don't know.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah, I
think you're right.
It's sort of emerged.
PROFESSOR: I thought
you all started on one.
Sounded to me like you were
all, I don't know what that note
was, but -- anybody
else notice that?
I mean, after all
that discussion.
Everybody just intuitively said,
okay, we're going to do over,
and that was pretty interesting.
And again, I was the only
non-playing observer,
but in addition to this concept,
of the range increasing and all
that kind of thing,
contracting, you're
also dealing with texture.
So the whole thing
could be looked
at as an exercise in texture.
Particularly in the beginning
part and the last part,
as I was hearing.
Which is interesting.
Which means that your
specific contributions,
it's the overall
that's more important.
To me, anyway.
I don't know what
you think about that.
PHIL SCARF: I don't know,
with so many people playing,
everyone has their
own contribution.
Everybody's listening.
And there's so much
going on, it's hard --
some people are probably trying
to pick out maybe what one
person is doing, or maybe others
are kind of trying to hear
the overall sound.
When you have so many
people improvising,
it's challenging to
figure out how to fit in.
Yes.
STUDENT 12: I thought
speaking of fitting in.
I think this was the
first time in this class,
for me, at least, that I
wasn't trying to fill a space.
I was just like, oh,
I'm just going to go.
Because we had talked about
having that type of texture.
And I think, most of the time
when you improvise, somebody
starts something, and then
somebody else comes in and is
trying to fill a
space that they left.
And this was different
because we were just, like,
who cares about
each other's space,
and just went all over it.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
That's right.
STUDENT 7: I think one thing
that really would have helped
is if we'd trickled
in at the beginning,
that way we could
have sort of set a --
STUDENT 12: I liked
it, I mean, we've
never sounded like that before.
PROFESSOR: The effect
was pretty strong.
STUDENT 7: I feel like we did
sort of start funneling in.
The beginning just
started as chaos,
everyone was doing
something different.
We did start to funnel
in towards the end.
We might have been
funneling in to two or three
different places, but
we were funneling.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
You know, part of
improvisation can be chaos.
It doesn't have to be.
But it can be.
So that's part of
the game, you know?
If it goes into chaos, then
where's it go from there,
you know?
Does something start to gel?
Or come together?
Improvisation, especially when
you're doing with a group,
it has a life of
its own, you know?
And everybody's kind
of going with that.
Anything else?
What else?
OK.
Cool.
So let's try
something different.
Let's try -- OK,
I'll take ideas.
Ideas about how to set
up an improvisation.
Let's say we want to use
the constrained range,
I want to do this constrained
range, confined range.
OK.
We use the confined range idea.
But this time we're
going to extrapolate it.
And instead of picking notes
that are close together,
pick three or four notes
that are far apart.
And use that.
But I also want to
change this density.
So that's it's not continuous
high, like everybody
playing all the time.
So I want to solicit some ideas
about how we should do that.
How can we make it thinner?
STUDENT 7: We could
designate people
who would be more drone,
lower, longer pitches.
And who would be higher,
melodic type instruments.
That way we can sort of
differentiate between that,
and not everyone's
trying to do melody.
PHIL SCARF: OK.
That's a cool idea.
So by default, people
would be droning.
And then those who are going
to play the so-called lead part
would emerge.
OK.
Yes?
STUDENT 2: We could maybe have
a shifting window of maybe two
or three people at a time, who
are out there trying to make
a new motif, or kind of -- even
for the people who are just
droning, they might
be playing something.
But maybe designate a
moving group of people.
Not any one, but like.
You know, Ben can
experiment more, I guess.
PHIL SCARF: Playing the lead --
we'll call it lead and drone.
Just to differentiate
the roles, right?
So having small groups of
two or three people at a time
playing the lead.
Right.
Yeah.
That's a good idea.
So any thoughts about
how do we implement that?
How are we going
to know who's going
to play the lead part
at any given time?
Any ideas?
STUDENT 2: You can just start
with first two or three,
and then when one drops
out, the next person --
PHIL SCARF: OK, that's fine.
Cool.
So we'll start with three.
When the first person drops
out, the next person adds in.
That person drops out,
the next person adds in.
And we work our way across
the room, how about that?
OK.
Great.
This is for the lead part.
By default, everyone's going
to be droning, more or less
all the time.
And then when it's your
turn to play the lead part,
you jump out, you
emerge out of that,
and you go into the lead part.
And I was just
thinking also, maybe
we should put in one
more element here.
Like a note density element.
Yeah.
Everybody's going to pick like
three or four notes, which
don't have to be the same notes.
You can pick whatever
notes you want.
And you could base it
on what the people are
playing who played before you.
Or not.
It's up to you.
But let's do this.
Let's start it at a
very high density,
and work our way
to a low density.
OK?
But still, the notes
should be rapid.
So to achieve a low density
with rapid notes, what
you have to do is maybe
play a few notes and stop.
Play a few notes and stop.
So that it's not as dense,
but when you play the notes,
you're playing rapid lines.
So let's not play sustained --
the lead players should not be
playing sustained notes.
It's only the droners who
are playing sustained.
And let's do the drone
-- let's pick a note.
Who wants to pick a
note for the drone?
A tonic?
F. OK.
Cool.
So let's start.
And we're going to start over
here and work our way around.
Three people at a time.
OK.
Is everybody ready?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL SCARF: Right.
Good.
So comments?
How well do you
think we followed
the framework, or the design?
STUDENT 7: We followed
it pretty well.
It seemed like we were keeping
to the groups of three.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
We were keeping to
the groups of three.
That's true.
I was kind of
helping that along.
Because sometimes
it was getting hazy.
But yeah.
STUDENT 13: I didn't hear
the change in note density,
I guess?
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
The change in note density
didn't really seem to happen.
It wasn't too obvious.
Maybe a little bit, but it
wasn't nearly as pronounced
as I was hoping it would be.
STUDENT 12: I
guess I wasn't sure
exactly what that meant
when you described it.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
Well I'll try demonstrating
that with my reed -- aw man,
I'll tell you, this weather.
When it's cold and it's dry
in here, the reed dries up.
While we're talking I'll
try to get this resolved.
Picking three or four notes
and only playing those notes.
I was hearing like scales and
different things going on,
which wasn't really
part of the design.
So that was the other
observation I had.
STUDENT 7: I
thought we were just
supposed to start with three
notes and then build out.
PHIL SCARF: Oh.
That's not what I had in mind.
But that's certainly
a possibility.
But it wasn't what I was
trying to communicate.
PROFESSOR: If I
could just interject.
It's almost the most difficult
thing, is just [INAUDIBLE]
a reduced parameter.
So three or four notes,
that's really hard.
Because our inclination
always is to expand.
So the idea of staying
with this limited
whatever it is, range
or density or something,
it's one of the
hardest things to do.
So just something
to keep in mind.
We'll probably try to work
on that as we go forward.
PHIL SCARF: I agree.
That's true.
It's a very natural tendency.
Once you start with
whatever the parameter is,
you try to build something.
OK.
So for example, I'm
going to pick three notes
and just play some rapid
lines with just three notes.
So that's pretty high density.
To go to lower density
without reducing the speed,
you just leave space.
So.
And you could reduce the density
without changing the speed.
So that's more like what
I was thinking about.
So I don't know if we
want to try it again.
Maybe try it again with that
in mind and see what we can do.
PROFESSOR: So just time-wise,
we have room for one more.
PHIL SCARF: OK.
That's cool.
So we'll do this.
So we'll do the
same basic thing,
with everybody
droning by default.
And then we'll have
our window of three.
And I may just do
the same thing.
So let's just start.
Yeah, still on the F.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHIL SCARF: Still have
a couple minutes, right?
OK, any comments?
That was much better.
Much closer to what
we were trying to do.
Yes.
Good.
So how did that feel?
Start to compare the last two,
from the performer's point
of view.
How did it feel
the play those two?
STUDENT 7: It's interesting.
Because we look at
it on a micro scale.
Each individual
person is playing
this random, chaotic
assortment of just three notes.
And when you look
on the macro level,
when everyone was
playing together,
it actually sort of made sense.
I don't know.
But if you just listen
to each individual part,
it really didn't make sense,
it was just sort of random.
PHIL SCARF: OK.
Anything else?
Other comments?
STUDENT 1: I feel like
high density is also
just as restricting
as like low density.
There's only certain
things that you
can play if you're
forced to play fast.
There's certain things when
you're forced to play slow.
But you're restricted
to those things.
PHIL SCARF: As opposed
to having a full pallet,
of all possibilities.
STUDENT 1: I didn't mean
restricted as a bad thing.
I meant, it's just
definitely more constraint
than I expected.
PHIL SCARF: Yeah.
You have to work within
certain limitations,
and it generates
a certain thing.
And, you know, these
kind of concepts --
it's great to think
about it ahead of time.
And have this design
worked out, and then try
to implement the design.
But you can also spontaneously
just play, and use these ideas
as you go.
And let the framework,
or let the whole design
itself kind of
evolve spontaneously.
It doesn't have to be
something that you've
planned out before hand.
PROFESSOR: The one
thing I would say
is I thought everybody,
comparing the two,
is the second one,
everybody was listening
much more closely
than I thought.
Which is why I think
it worked out better.
Because you got to
listen as much as
you make your individual
contributions.